welcome back I'm assuming Jim is not
going number one well he was uh-huh
but then he confided to me and this is
in confidence so if I'm breaking any
rules I apologize he said that he would
have to make soon
I didn't think soon meant immediately
but I can only assume that it does is
this cocoa by Black Caviar believe so
this is the song that is put Troy in new
tits that's what it's known as well
welcome back Jim we'll be here at some
point when he's done defecating I would
assume but Brian Johnson is here from
the comic book man what's going on man
not a lot I can verify Jim was in the
bathroom and he was about to do
something I walked out as he was walking
in
so was it one of the Travis you telling
me was it one of those moments where he
went to the urinal and then probably
finished at the urinal went to the stall
I'm assuming so because I finished at
the urinal before him and he said Ric in
a minute and I haven't seen him since
that's always very embarrassing I never
I never like to do weight you know I've
got my own issues but you do what I
never like to go to the urinal and then
turn around and go into a stall I'll go
in the urinal and if I realize this is a
stall trip and I didn't realize I will
leave the bathroom I will do a lap I
will come back into the bathroom and go
into the stall so there's no well if
nobody's there I'll do it if nobody's in
the bathroom then I'll just going in
what all the same people are still in
the bathroom when you go back in then I
just wash my hands and leave I can't
yeah it's just like Oh wash my hands
again got to go for that second Grampa
Simpson when he walks into the board
don't exactly but put the hat on the hat
rack do the circle hat comes right back
on that sounds like next level bathroom
stuff like I have something where if I
go in and it's a stall visit in a public
place because I don't have stalls in my
house I don't know why I clarified but
like I can not if somebody walks in like
it has to be completely empty because I
don't want anyone hearing anything I
want anyone hearing any splashes or
anything right you know yeah I can't go
into a stall like if there's other
people in stalls that's fine but if I
can't have people see me go into a stall
that I hear maybe like even though now
I'm to see your shame I just don't want
that ya know I was about to say maybe in
a movie theater something but no even a
time
movie theater or something nowhere do I
want that to happen so if I go in
knowing it's time for a stall trip and I
see a whole bunch of people are standing
around especially if they go like oh hey
man I go hey just walk to the urinal
you're really punch my cheeks you're
concerned about what people think of you
I guess so
I don't give a [ __ ] but I do you really
do right well like when you spilled the
soda in at the chick-fil-a parking lot
that's exactly right
you were too embarrassed to go get I
didn't want to yeah no I know yeah
because I was like people will be in my
business at that point or if you fall
asleep on the train you've said that you
will you won't make it look like let
anybody know that you miss miss like if
I miss my stop yes I will completely
know Sal missing my stop and just get
off at the next one and figure it out
yeah no I don't want I don't want
anybody to see me in a moment of
weakness I would tell everyone that I
miss I miss my stop tweeting it yeah we
were did you just use the urinal and
then turn and use the stall I was
pissing and I went you know what it's
time to [ __ ] I really did I do double
duty I die [ __ ] I double dipped and
you have no shame in that that's what we
were talking about no I had to [ __ ] what
I'm gonna do not go exactly I gotta fly
in a little while I can't I can't
because everyone's in that room for the
exact same reason right you feel so
self-conscious yeah yeah I like to [ __ ]
private though I'm weird like I don't
like the noises you know I just I like a
stall open next to me it's almost like
buying a [ __ ] a seat next to you on a
plane so no one sits there I like my
space well you like your space and also
if someone else is in it like I don't
know if the same holds for females but
guys like is there anything grosser than
a dude like yeah you shouldn't have to
push that hard if you're in a public
restroom you should have just waited
it'll come out eventually yeah you need
to push that Rob Rob time he pushes when
he knows that I'm in in there he's extra
loud is that right Rob yes it is true
you're a disgusting person yeah well why
do you do that we got to give you the
grunts yeah you know the earth Rob's a
big grunter do you know that it bothers
Travis when you do that yes and so you
do that if you see Travis going we
picked a stall next to him absolutely
okay he's done that too he has done that
and you know it's Rob from the high
waters that you see under the under the
star wall yeah I'm like oh it's not
shorts weather this most
Robb's clothes don't fit him that well
do you wear high waters like fries
practically no not intentionally no yeah
he wears those like you know that like a
gay real-estate agents where they're
[ __ ] really tight and they stop right
above the ankle and Rob where's yeah I
you do wear high waters I I do have some
short pants there's a very short pant
yeah I have short legs so I kind of cuff
him up a little bit well he's five five
five six hmm yeah so like on your on
your save the date yeah that was a
little a little joke weren't enough
those were not cuffed though I feel like
they were just pants that didn't fit I
think they were a little small yeah yeah
yeah maybe a little because he was
wearing khakis and high tops but the
khakis didn't come to the high top you
know what I mean they were like oh
really sure above your high top shoe
they might have been yeah and it was his
save the day I was like this is a photo
with your ankle and I can I can see it
all that's terrible well that's why you
wear uh you wear long socks no no no you
get pants to fit man yeah Oliver Twist
he like a Mexican guy my my pant size is
like a 28 28 so it's a year then waist
guy exactly there may relink City oh
yeah yeah
did you did you notice that pant thing
when the save-the-dates got printed yes
did you say anything no is it because
your fiance was like this is the photo
yeah she kind of liked it yeah my
brother you know text me ah check out
short pants here but you didn't do you
have the picture can I see the picture I
have to save the day but we got a look
at it first thing I noticed I don't
remember the pants how old are you 27
Wow looks great for only Sam you look
really young Leo like you're getting
married
even 27 I think is so young to get
married it is happy you've been in oh no
no way no and at this point no one would
marry me
I'm at this like right now I'm from like
the Anthony ku Mia school of dating
where like everyone is a minimum of 20
years younger than me yeah yeah like any
girl I date it just looks like it's the
final stage of the grooming process how
long even with your girlfriend well the
one before this one I was it was like 12
years and all I was bad bad like my
whole 12 years was bad
let's not get crazy probably 11 fighting
too much fighting fighting and she was
like kind of legit mentally unstable but
I had known her a while and I it's one
of those things where I'm like I can
help her to a point where like I sort of
got gaslighted into believing that like
oh I deserve this [ __ ] you know and
right it was it was pretty bad and then
finally last September she was like I'm
out of here
which is like what I need cuz I will I
don't know why I'll suffer on end for
years but I need somebody be like [ __ ]
you and then walk out right did you
grieve her for a while did you try to
get her back no no I was so happy I gave
her $1,000 - are you done yeah I bought
her a train ticket because she want to
go to Oregon for whatever reason I gotta
care okay go to the [ __ ] moon oh you
know yeah well like Ralph Kramden bang
zoom oh you get her on that richard
branson spaceship if that's where she
wanted to go if that's what she wanted
have you talked to her since a few times
because she essentially like I have this
weird thing where I have I have a kid
she has Down syndrome but it's not
really my kid she's my niece it's my
sister's kid but she's lived with me for
six or seven years now she's 12 mm-hmm
so the girl I was dating was there the
whole time so she kind of like raised
her right so that was the other thing
was that I was very nervous that how
sage my kid was gonna handle it when her
basically her mother figure like walked
away if I had known that she would have
handled it that well I would have done
it way yeah oh you were kind of keeping
it keep around for her yeah yeah cuz I
was like I don't know how she's gonna
react or or like she won't have she
won't have her around she's always been
there so it's sort of a weird part
probably kids you got to think of like
alright yeah and a feel about this other
person not being here yeah and I did it
for a long time because of that and then
when I saw how sort of like it's not
like she didn't miss her at all but I
guess you dishes didn't process she
handled it yeah yeah she handled it like
people handle [ __ ] does this
relationship to urine now did you go
like oh my god people can be happy in
relationships uh well saying I'm happy
would be a little bit of a stretch okay
like you're a bit of a glutton for
punishment yeah and other things I think
it's it's one of those things were
with a relationship right now I'm just
so suspicious of everything still like
I'm on high alert now this would have
been like she left in September and I've
been seeing this girl since November
around there okay so the scars are still
fresh yeah yeah so this girl who's only
24 I feel bad for cuz I'm like I'm all
[ __ ] up right and I tell her that you
know are you more than 10 years older
than her so when they say daddy and it
works out mathematically you want to
tell me how old her dad was for the
longest time and then she's like okay
fine he's 55 and I'm 50 right there your
peers and I was a little bit
disappointed cuz I wanted to be older
right yeah I've never done that one
either I'm getting there though but I
have never done I've never been older
than the parents yeah you'll get there
keep keep those goals along stick it in
my mouth pop pop oh my god
pants don't fit do they oh yeah no those
are that's an ill-fitting trouser it is
it is a fool so you saw it right away
you knew you're gonna get made fun of
but you knew mama like that photo so
right yeah yeah yeah the side kiss you
look a little rock wall painting yeah
well we know what we know who wears the
pants in that relationship and who wears
the capris that's right that's right
absolutely five years five years that's
a healthy normal relations towards me
nuts
I don't get it I don't understand
age-appropriate yeah at five years you
kind of know right I mean even though
it's still easy to think you do the
crazy ones have been the best [ __ ]
though the problem is the ones like you
don't any like I like my a seat normal
girls are gonna do that but he looks for
the crazy girl that's the best the best
time oh wow you know if she puts her
face in a pillow and cries about her
past after we [ __ ] that was a great
time I love you know what I love about
this topic and did Troy like for
everybody but Troy is like you know if
you guys want to talk to me I'm here if
not I'll sit in the cut no problem but
you bring up crazy girls and Troy's like
if I may enter Jan I mean [ __ ] yeah it
is the truth
yeah crazy girls are the most fun they
are the most fun man yeah in a short
term short term long term long term 12
years thick right dirty talk right
right long-term she I we I do a podcast
with my friend Walt's who's also in
comic book man and my other friend Brian
Quinn who's on Impractical Jokers and
we've done it for like eight years
and a long time ago we started play this
game called one true three which is
essentially two truths in a lie and my
truth was and it was with this girl that
one time we had sex and I held a loaded
gun to the back of her head like I was
doing her from behind oh my gosh said
she knew it's not like I was like oh my
god were you doing and another girl was
like when she heard that she was like I
want you to do that to me like I want
you to hold a loaded gun to me and it's
I find that girls today are so much more
open and forward with what they want
yeah like growing up wasn't it just like
well maybe I'll get over the bra and
like that would have been a huge
achievement now it's like first date
they're like come on my face
[ __ ] yeah yeah at least I hope
they said a gun play if not they can be
like what did you do that for
so you're holding a loaded gun yeah to
the back of a girl's head well this girl
actually the first time it's Brian
Johnson by the way yeah when I say it
out loud but the first time I met her I
was probably like 20 and she was six or
seven which sounds how long after this
incident happen
it was first two years later now she we
reconnected when she was 18 okay I was
probably 34 at the time something like
that and we started dating and it wasn't
too long after that that the gun came
out but it was just one of those things
like it was my grandmother's it was my
grandfather's gun he died gave it to my
grandmother took it and then my
grandmother was afraid that my cousin
who was like on heroin was gonna steal
it and sell it so she gave it to me to
hold and it was just like this tiny
little 22 like a 38 one of the two and
she we were we were having sex and she
was like get that gun she's like where's
that gun and it was like in the bedside
table and I think she was like holding
on me and I said all right but like if
they asked for something like that like
this to for her was it the same fantasy
cuz she had asked you to do if she much
wanted to see what that was like to look
at uh probably yeah I think that she was
probably also because she was young she
was like I want to try a bunch of
different stuff now
I was in my thirties and I had it it had
never occurred to me because I didn't
have it right up until recently to hold
a gun on somebody but there is the fact
that it has to be a loaded gun like
there is some danger in that even if you
know like it's not going to
intentionally shoot me like there is the
fact that it's a loaded gun accidents
happen yeah right that's where the
danger have to be loaded that's the
other thing but like I guess in order
for it to work like to truly work you've
totally an element of danger right you
know right that would scare me [ __ ]
somebody if I had a gun yeah I wouldn't
trust myself to not drop it like that
[ __ ] cop dancing the girl my gosh
like they go off sometimes that would
scare me too much my dick would wilt
know what did it go off what it didn't
take a gun to do that no but I'll be
trying to flip my nipples that gonna be
point shoot myself
what was that FBI guy did he did he pull
the trigger my mistake yeah I was gonna
say cuz normally they don't just like
hit the ground and it fell no he grabbed
it he probably grabbed by the trigger
panicking so no he could get his gun
he's embarrassed it went off when he
picked it up good answers obviously went
winning some sort of contest back flip
there goes the gun injured some guy's
leg I hope he doesn't get charged though
like he just made a mistake the guy's
not dead oh wait we shouldn't try to
destroy his livelihood even know it had
nothing to do with us is oh it seriously
injured huh Oh attorney oh boy yep you
guys gettin sued there you guys gettin
serious
oh maybe you guys really hurt you kind
of got to punish a guy for yeah yeah man
off on the dance floor I know I just
wanna see the guy fired I'm curious to
know what the injury was though like I
don't think yeah bullet in the leg but I
mean like did it hit like where did it
hit that a shatter his kneecap didn't
like was it just like a crazy man yeah
yeah like the edited shutter his femur
yeah I don't know if it's an attorney
it's probably far worse than it actually
was
no it struck the end up just what you
said dad popped up he didn't scroll to
it okay that one might not have an
operation here yeah when you scroll down
the ad pops up because they want you to
subscribe see [ __ ] you what is that the
Wall Street Journal
now addendum pouch [ __ ] you see cuz they
want you to read a little bit yourself
yeah
yeah really is funny these newspapers
they're like guys you want to read our
story you got to pay just charge for the
ads on your page stupid right
same way newspapers work tested for
alcohol I mean you would assume he was
drinking right not with moves like that
he was good he had his dexterity about
him except when he was holding his gun
well you know the counted yeah exactly
nobody's really paying attention to his
perfect backflip that was really good
there was great news right before he was
having fun
did you hit the I get some hits some
some vein in the guy's legs oh sure it's
not good no it's not good I mean yeah
getting shot in the leg you can probably
figure out a reason to sue for that yeah
and not only that but you're like thank
Christ it was my leg right I look higher
yeah shot in the dick like that kid that
got is the shark that is yeah Brazil
yeah bit his [ __ ] femur and it got
him from like the side and it ripped his
whole dick and femur off oh my last
words would be do not save me let me
just bleed out
you'd be like Lieutenant Dan yelling it
for us with your dick left on the field
on the beach [ __ ] his hand over his but
yeah lifeguards were really brave to go
in there and get her here's dick pitting
off by a shark I mean I saw somebody's
comment they're like the only country
where EMS workers don't wear shoes that
was so [ __ ] creep I've seen the
footage it's very upsetting
yeah I've not heard but it's very
disturbing nor will I see the footage
why you won't swim in shark-infested
waters I wouldn't do it before alright
let's still don't you prefer a pool yeah
I never understand people's obsession to
like be with the animals like there's
one reason why we as humans have
achieved what we've achieved and gotten
to the top of the food chain because we
figured out how to build structures we
crawled other primordial ooze for a
[ __ ] reason because it sucks in there
right why are we all going back and
swimming in the ocean and rivers and
ponds and lakes with leeches and all
kinds of I don't get it
we figured out how to make tools we make
guns we made buildings we make cars we
made airplanes that's where we belong
and boats so you can ride over top of
the water but you don't have to go in it
exactly that's why we don't fight deer
we shoot them yeah there's too much
under there man like and there's like
every single organism in there is
pissing right and [ __ ] yeah so now
you're swimming around in the
just piss and [ __ ] everywhere it's a
good point and they don't have to
breathe it in because they don't breathe
under there so they don't care that's
true they're all pissing and [ __ ]
bunch of whale logs very much whales
[ __ ] is at the bottom has anybody ever
seen well [ __ ] float by I probably
doesn't float it probably sinks I don't
know about that dunce I think so know
depending on what these whales eat eat a
lot of fish and float let's see oh my
god grilling [ __ ] yeah it's just a
battle movement just like a brown powder
hood well yeah because it also the water
just died ludes everything so probably
wouldn't float right it would just kind
of become it's all diarrhea it would
just be diarrhea into the water home all
those oh my god whales really [ __ ] they
just diarrhea everywhere the water
turned a deep red brown color as the
substance filled the water magic rusted
by a whale oh god I thought it was just
a fart photo of deep space yeah yeah big
brown clouds big billowy brown clouds oh
my god I think there's whales that are
proud of their big duties like Jim I
think so I know I wonder they even
notice well there aren't that much to
live for I mean how much is going on
under the water you know it's a boring
existence yeah probably
all that's going on under the water is
is something trying to get me yeah
that's their whole life is like looking
over their shoulders something is gonna
try to eat me or bite me or whatever
there are the only ones that kind of get
wet like blue whales no one [ __ ] with
them except people do but I mean other
animals don't ever [ __ ] like a 100 foot
blue whale being a whale in the ocean or
being a fish in the ocean is like be
it's like being like Takashi 6-9 or a
gangster rapper where it's like at any
moment my entire life is just you know I
might be [ __ ] like I might be killed
at any moment or you're at a club with a
clumsy FBI guy or that happens yeah wow
did you uh do you guys hear the new
nickname for our president no I went
crazy for have not because I really I
get my news solely from this yes and
every Commission may be slightly skewed
yes I do like I do like the addicting
did yes Kellyanne Conway was on CNN and
she did she shared with the world her
new nickname for the president yes and I
thought it was just brilliant commander
in chief you don't know it she's a
commander of cheese no thanks you
corrected it too commander of cheese
then she went off chief it's not even
really that of is wrong you're not a
commander of chief he's a commander he's
that'll be McMurphy he was commander of
chief cheese bad was somewhere Mayor
McCheese is like that's my [ __ ] deal
right yeah Mayor McCheese pissed that
Kellyanne Conway is giving it's just
such a little kid stuff like there's
something in all of us to go like yeah
is it Jesus not the commander of cheese
stupid especially in today's world where
people are so sanctimonious and judgy
and holier than thou it liked so to
watch any one misstep right you know
like the meat to people like the the
guys who are who are like up in your
face about me too and then it turns out
they did something oh yeah
good god yeah [ __ ] you you're not
perfect we like watching people get
burned
who and do we like watching anybody get
burned even people that don't deserve it
but especially we think they deserve it
it's fun to watch I just liked it yeah I
mean I feel like this is something that
people on all sides of the political
spectrum can get behind it's funny that
Kellyanne Conway said commander of
cheese it is like whether you voted for
whoever you voted for even if you didn't
vote everybody can be like Oh imagine if
the president was actually a commander
of cheese be a pretty cool position yeah
you would think that whoever doesn't
like Trump would probably like adopt it
right there would be mugs and shirts no
like cuz he's cheesy or whatever right
and then all the people who do like
Trump will be like oh you can't say that
we're cheese heads made own it just take
it all way too seriously like come on
everybody relax
just stop it it's really fun to watch
everybody get upset over nothing over
nothing it's just cycles do you think
that people that many people are upset
because like the people I interact with
in everyday life they don't seem that
worked up about the [ __ ] that you see on
social media no but you know I don't
know you never know with people until
the subject comes up like everybody's
fine
and then there's one guy in the group
who like you bring up like isn't it
funny and she said cheese and there's
one person that goes like it's not it's
not so if nothing that man is doing is
funny and he shouldn't be our president
you know like okay I'm going I don't
know what I stepped in here I really
shouldn't have brought it up at all I
thought the cheese thing you know
there's always I have encountered it a
few times like there's one person in the
group that this is why we can't bring it
up because he takes it way too way too
seriously ruins the fun yeah I was in LA
this past winter and I did a live show
with a couple of Mike and Bing from
comic book men and I started talking
about you know my 12 year old kid who
has Down syndrome who has not had a
period yet now as a guy who also has
never had a period righty that's a
[ __ ] frightening proposition to be
like because I [ __ ] with her constantly
so she doesn't believe anything I say so
if I'm like one day a bunch of blood
which like the slightest scratch and
she's like ready to go to the hospital
blood is just going to like pour forth
like a [ __ ] volcano from your vagina
right she'd be like what are you talking
about and shut up like she just wouldn't
believe me so I'm like how do like it's
gonna happen and I'm just praying it
happens in school which I know is gonna
be like a Carrie moment for her but if
that saves me sure so you're right right
you won't have to deal with although
then you'll have to be the one that she
goes oh my god this happened you're like
yep and that's every month from now on I
drag her by the hair to her prayer
closet right yeah but a lady came up to
me afterwards and she's like you know
you shouldn't shame her for that
and I was like you know she's not in the
audience right like I'm just sort of
yeah joking around about something that
actually like scares me like I don't
know your story yeah like I went to
Target because I have to get these good
mic cannons here you wanna bring him in
yeah yeah because I wanna know if he's
had his period yet oh me too yeah he
might tell me what to do I I went to
Target and I'm looking at the pads and
I'm like I don't know what the [ __ ] to
buy so I go back home and I get my
girlfriend and I bring it to the aisle
and I'm like what what should I buy here
and she goes
these are diapers
adult diapers like that's how little I
know my god damn it but this lady was
just like right in my ass about shaming
her and all this other [ __ ] and I'm like
dummy you have no idea what you're
talking about you just ciao
yeah I'm joking around about something
that any - you're comfortable yeah like
your sister's daughter it's my sister's
daughter yeah she's just her alive yeah
she just can't care for yeah she she
went through some financial stuff so
yeah I've had her for quite a while
okay and I'm like super close to her
it's like I never wanted a kid never
wanted to get married never got married
will she go back to your sister or no no
I don't think so I shall probably hang
with me yeah but that's like when people
decide to make judgments based on your
relationship like with a kid like with
your kid yeah are you talking about not
I'm gonna talk about that dude
everyone's making judgments cuz Mike
Hanna politely refused our invitation
okay I see yesterday's uncle Paul with
the feet straightening I was like thank
you next level darkness I was like that
is awesome I had lunch with a rock not
to love a few weeks ago hope you didn't
pay yeah I must have been an expensive
endeavor and I've been a fan of yours
Jim for some time and I say the textbook
definition of irony is a taking chip to
make me realize what a genius Jim
actually is hahaha like it is I cannot
tell you how much I love watching chip
with my girl on YouTube oh I used to
just listen to it and then somebody's
like no no no you got to watch it and I
didn't even know there's a video so I
went back and I was like holy [ __ ] this
is awesome thank you that my favorite
thing to do hello Mike how's it going
good but I completely agree by the way I
came in late but yeah it's it's one of
my favorite thing thank you love it
thank you you guys come on I'd love to
have you both on oh yeah more than
welcome I'm always embarrassed with my
people on really yeah cuz I was you
don't realize that everybody loves it is
humiliating cuz they're so silly it's so
stupid and they got like we had Kendra
in yesterday Kendra Sunderland came on
she was good on it but or Joe Mackey
c'mon I'm like but you gotta tell them
like I don't break character and it's
not like I'm Andy I just don't that's
too embarrassing to come in and out of
then you have they're like look at like
your gym or what the [ __ ] you doing I
know hey I know you as you shut up it's
a car Brennan was really good on it I
love Kevin is [ __ ] great he comes on
he's really funny because he enjoys it
Mark Norman's great yeah every
combination was really really good oh
yeah [ __ ] DePaul he has I texted him
back and like do a great job not old
peep nothing I've gotten radio silence
from Nick yes a second chip he was
probably a little annoyed eeeh to drive
all the way into the city and then he
realizes what it is but still he was
great yeah it was one episode I didn't
care for and it was only because Ari was
bullying chip and calling him a piece of
[ __ ] that's the thing that you realize
that the audience is on chips idly even
when I go on and I'm like chip I'm not
playing along I'm not wearing this hat
like I don't like you yeah I don't know
why I'm here people are like what the
[ __ ] to say he's better than the
characters a total unlikable scum
hateable yeah he does everything wrong
he's a selfish narcissist oh that's
right but he makes people feel better
about themselves yeah but is it also
like one of those it's almost like
eastbound and down where it's hateable
but like a game time like you can kind
of identify with the worst attributes of
his personality yeah that's why I really
like it cuz I'm like oh I have that kind
of childish like almost innocence to it
but then also you're selfish and out for
yourself I totally identify with because
the Khomeini's at Duke is it's it's
almost like it's so much fun to reach
for the worst joke like you're supposed
to reach the opposite of everything that
we do it's kind of fun to reach for this
cause you mind works the same way right
you're still going through options but
instead of grabbing from the top you're
grabbing from the bottom just more fun
yeah which which joke here is gonna stop
the room yeah even though I just stopped
the room three minutes ago which is
gonna sound I gotta do it again like
they just pick up the pace like that's
my favorite when like the room gets
stopped and everybody else like picks up
the pace and goes like okay we're back
on track and then boom right away again
watching Anthony get uncomfortable like
there's time he's literally like oh like
I can't
like cuz I'm looking at him and he'll
stop making eye contact
which is so much fun like he'll just
kind of look down in a way like he's
embarrassed that I know I'm doing it
right yeah when he's uncomfortable yeah
there should be a thing where most of
the room should not be having fun no
right like if everybody is having a
great time then we're all you know Jim
has become a parody I love when sequins
Amazon I love Sam on I think you're
great on it yeah yeah when that makes
one of us man yeah I drove from San
Francisco to LA with my wife and I made
her listen to chip a bunch and she want
she was furious got it a little bit but
then like turn it off and then would
then she drop something was like to me
about Kate Spade and I texted back
because I feel like chip I don't know
what this says about me he makes you
think differently about humor like you
start to think of those bad jokes and
she's talking about Kate Spade and I
text back more like late Spade and very
happily you're both welcome to come love
to have you both although as a person is
you know got a home and a family in this
whole thing nothing ruins my weekend
more than a Sunday morning and I look up
and jess is drinking her coffee out of a
cup that says put a drink up in this mug
just just everywhere yeah that's cuz she
hates you and she does know how to say
it Brian a Mike I don't know nice to
meet you man who do ya this is Brian yep
this is Mike very cool
our others were super creative with our
names yeah ery
yeah yeah my mom's like I know how I'll
set him apart from everyone but doesn't
high school want to change my name to ji
mi girl yeah
it's worse than me wanting to change my
name no I I was almost Demetrius it was
between Michael and Demetri are you
Greek no
no like that even remotely close I'm
Irish and not even a pinch black that's
the name you Demetrius I think my dad he
had some bad ideas Wow yeah but that's a
strong name though like oh my god it's
my cannon like I imagined yeah my cannon
like a cop TV show yeah and there was
yeah I think there was a show when and
Cannon yes he's a big fat guy Anthony
always did a great impression but he had
a [ __ ] phone in his car that was like
you literally lift it it was it got a
home phone in his car I think I was
cannon yeah I'm gonna start pitching
that as a reboot
speaking of Kate Spade her husband yeah
made a statement I was going to therapy
the other day and it's by that and I see
all these [ __ ] reporters and cops
outside of this Park Avenue plan and I
looked it up like what the file that's
my where she left yeah she [ __ ]
Anthony had such a funny joke about it
he tweeted it Kate Spade's no one who
could make a scarf or choker but she had
mental illness you know like for a long
time and she wouldn't get hell I gets
really sad yeah wouldn't get help and
it's like you know you got issues
worried about her [ __ ] brand isn't
she Minds flooding it with booze right
she says no maybe used to protect the
daughter some people say yes I don't
know if she drank or not well it's one
of them is interested in protecting the
daughter yeah yeah all right I can [ __ ]
hold note that one it's really selfish
when you figure out the context like
that's terrible yeah Ashley blame her
she blamed the husband right yeah yeah
here I'm gonna curse you with a lifetime
of regret right and Sanders I saw
someone blame Trump for it like the
thief used to go she didn't have the
money Kate Spade before the hundred
million you [ __ ] idiots right she
literally refused to God and her sister
said I'm not surprised by this we tried
to get her into treatment and she was
ready to go her sister even said I'll go
with you I'll go with you I'll stay with
you we could talk about our childhood
and she said she was packed and ready to
go in the morning they even flew in the
rehab people the mental health it flew
in for her cuz she is who she is and in
the last minute she backed out it was
her choice yeah it's sad but she made
that choice
he said that Kate suffered from
depression and anxiety for many years
she was actively seeking help and
working closely with doctors to treat
her disease one that takes far too many
lives we were in touch with her the
night before and she sounded
happy there was no indication and no
warning that she would do this it was a
complete shock and it clearly wasn't her
there were personal demons she was
battling if she drank you could see how
that would happen at night you know
you're thinking about the action move
that's six months ago you know yeah I
mean also isn't that kind of a common
thing with people who commit suicide Oh
is the night before they're kind of
happy and they feel at peace and it
seems as though they could it's because
they know death is on the horizon
something right yeah they're probably in
a good mood because like finally the
[ __ ] lights shut off tomorrow unless
it's just one of those manic things
where she went so manic in the moment
right I guess they could be a rash
decision to I know the jury I think I'm
Robin Williams because she became
obsessed with Robin suicide his last
days he was calling people and telling
them like I love you so much it was
really sad he kept calling like his this
one person he knew and going like I love
you guys so much fun I'm like almost
like he was making sure people know he
loved them and he was saying goodbye it
was really sweet yeah yeah the two
things in life that like it doesn't
matter what people say it just it has no
effect depression and when I was
addicted to painkillers like there's
nothing anyone could say that would be
like hey stop taking these painkillers
and when we're really depressed there's
nothing anyone could say like chin up
away like it'll be all right
how do that actually gets annoying yeah
yeah she's made me feel better though
yeah there really is not sometimes
somebody can you know sometimes somebody
can kick you in the ass in a certain way
and be logical but like you're in a
relationship any people going like Oh at
least you learn you can love it's like
go [ __ ] yourself I know you mean well
[ __ ] you yeah no platitudes please yeah
so how did you get off of painkillers I
went to rehab out in LA mm-hmm really
expensive it like a celebrity like rich
person you meet any celebrities while
you were there I did I'm not allowed to
say his name but I didn't know who he
was I had to watched his show his show
had been off for like 20 rhymes with
Barty Fang this would have been six
years ago
oh cool it was house Hugh Laurie
it was but then the guy found out that I
was on TV and he became like consumed
with me he wanted me to move into his
private little cabin and [ __ ] and I'm
like probably to talk about stuff you
probably related to you like aren't we
kids understand the business yeah we
both were on painkillers too so that was
the thing what it's a way difficult
thing that's a hard one right yeah my
god which painkillers they were
oxycodone oh my god because I didn't
have health insurance at the time and my
knee was all [ __ ] up from arthritis so
my doctor started giving me percocet and
then he started giving me the oxycodone
and then somebody else was taking
oxycodone for their back but they didn't
need it so then I started taking that as
well and then I started spending like 2
grand a week on stuff outside of that
like it was a lot I was taking a lot I
think you're not [ __ ] oh my god I have a
picture of it looks like it's insane how
big this is
I was I was probably on the toilet for
with no exaggeration 8 to 9 hours
standing up sitting down
go get prune juice go get like anything
and finally when when I passed it it was
like I know how Jim feels and I'm a dick
I gave my my girlfriend at the time gave
me an enema which is not a good egg she
did have some really care about her and
it didn't work and then I gave myself an
enema and that's when it finally worked
it was how did it feel to finally [ __ ]
relief like as if I found out I didn't
have cancer I would have rather had
known I had cancer I was gonna die the
next day then go through that [ __ ]
eight to nine hours Wow
yeah I like it a lot of painkillers [ __ ]
up you're [ __ ] yeah I've taken
oxycodone before like after after a
surgery or something like that and I
just couldn't get into it because it
made me so nauseous and also I tried to
[ __ ] on it and was completely like just
inapt oh you a limp yeah happy for me
out of water yeah I was having sex with
in college too and we were going for
like a while and I think we both were a
little drunk too because I looked down
like I was like um killing it and I
wasn't even inside of her a remotely
lawful whets lug on there
I have to like try it literally like
Jimmy my dick next yeah and kind of
profit it that's why they call it yeah
I've done that believe me it's like
we're gonna hold a [ __ ] open and just
kind of motion the painkillers like
lower testosterone and plus I was fat so
it's just like the same thing Dan's like
in the event you can get a hard-on
it [ __ ] your dick right oh can you but
if you test Lois testosterones you can
play blow loads inside not I don't want
to risk that but yeah if I got to load
but one time
this is discovery I don't think I've
ever told anyone this but it was like
what I had just gotten back from rehab
and I was still like your head is still
[ __ ] up now suboxone you're on all
this other [ __ ] and she was blowing me
and I accidentally pissed in her mouth
like when you go to the water fountain
and it's way too much water pressure
that's great you pissed in her mouth
yeah yeah so this is just one rehab trip
and then it did it just the one rehab
trip and then then I got the knee
operation and they put me back on
painkillers which of course why wouldn't
you do that and not monitor so I was on
them for a little while after that until
the doctor cut me off then I took
suboxone for a while which is equally as
hard to get off of how are we on that
probably about a year and a half until I
was like I just want it like what
motivated me was the doctor was such a
pain in the ass I had to go see him
every three weeks and it would be like
two hours every time so I was like [ __ ]
it I don't want to do this anymore so I
just started weaning myself down and
that the part that you have to get to is
so small you almost can't see it and
then after that it's about a month of
insomnia my friend Jay Mewes who was a
heroin for a while he said that's what
that's what you're gonna hate the most
is the insomnia that comes after you get
off everything right and it was about a
good month where you're like a key--and
you can't sleep and [ __ ] yeah your mind
is racing yeah yeah and you're like if I
just took this [ __ ] then this would go
away but you're like can't do it can't
do it yeah I guess that's what tricks
you right like I feel bad I need to feel
better like I just just do this and I'll
feel better yeah try melatonin
yeah yeah coach sheep yeah number of
things swarm up a glass of milk it's the
same [ __ ] we make that make my throat
all clogged turtle dairy farts and back
yeah
[Music]